to continue with our plenary session I
have the pleasure in the honor to invite
our next keynote speaker on to the stage
His Excellency Dmitrich eTCO the first
deputy minister of communications and
digitalization of Belarus is here with
us
Dimitri please join me on stage and
deliver your keynote speech thank you
well as this ladies and gentlemen it's a
pleasure for me to participate in such
an established conference and I'd like
to send the organizers for providing me
an opportunity to address you with a
short speech about my country and about
our vision of our future so you can see
on this screen some figures about my
country you know the the Belarus is
post-soviet country any country in the
Eastern Europe
it's not very big it's not very rich but
we believe we strongly believe that the
future of our economy and the future of
our society is digital so or we have
made several steps on this on the level
of the state to provide the Digital
Agenda for our country
we know that the development of Internet
in the modern world is on the one hand
an important indicator of the economic
development of the state and at the same
time the driving force behind the
economic progress services of fixed
broadband become everyday welfare for
the population and integral tool of
professional activity in many spheres
the Republic of Belarus
as a state integrated in the European
and world digital ecosystem can it
remained aloof from the global processes
of the in the field of ICT the
development of information society is
one of the national priorities of
Republic of Belarus we have several
state programs and is a National Digital
Agenda
which says the key indicators we are
going to achieve in next five years we
have started our program several years
ago and now we have some achievements
you see this ICT development the index
of the ITU with where the city second in
zero
and also we are proud to be the 21st
country in the ranking of the Commission
for fixed broadband access index so on
the next slide you can see some figures
about the broadband penetration for with
different technologies yeah so we have
around 3.8 million households in our
country so the three million households
is fixed broadband houses our mobile
penetration is better but we are if we
are speaking about the technologies
everything is not so well for us we
think we can make better so you see when
we have started our last program all the
broadband on almost 80 percent of the
broadband was was xDSL technologies but
for now we have 40 percent for XSL and
40% for FTTH it's a dip on technology
made by our national operators the bell
telecom company it was made by the state
regulation from the one side also the
national telecommunications of right
operator bell telecom is a national
company it's 100 percent belongs to the
state and they are providing this
national plan for broadband for
everywhere in the country for every city
not only the capital but also for rural
areas and we are proud that for now we
are more or less decreases gap between
the rural and urban areas and for the
next stage we are planing that in two
years we will have the 65% of 50 th
penetration in our country and for
search not only the regulation needed
from the state but also some foreign
direct financing from the budget but we
are we think that for Belarusian marking
which is underdeveloped we can say yeah
because in Belarus the average ARPU is 6
euros per subscriber so it's not a big
money it's a big companies and don't
come into the country and don't make in
the big investment so we are trying to
do our best from one side stimulating
the companies to invest more and
providing some new opportunities for
business for private business
and from the other side to make some key
pies for our bill telecom company to
provide the better services for people
everywhere in the country so it's an
international Internet bandwidth in
Belarus people like to use internet very
much so every year we need to make some
additional capacity because people are
open to foreign resources and they want
to use it in television notes and in
communication services and so this is
official ITU information and some
indicator we have set for then for
current here and for 2020 and the
overall goal of our country is to become
a bit high in the idea I rank and also
to become one of the top 30 countries in
the world so maybe that's all thank you
for attention and I'd like only to add
that we strongly believe that the future
of broadband of ftth is great and we are
going to be part of it
thank you very much
if you have some questions okay answer
thank you very much I think that we will
have a lot of follow-up questions over
lunch and over at a coffee breaks and I
encourage you to ask questions because I
think that is a very interesting country
case